you
the honest company stepped up everyone I
approached was skeptical even my husband
cash thought the idea was too big
Jessica Alba co-founder of the honest
company the artist company took it's one
word to the next level
not only did co-founders Jessica Alba
and Christopher Gavigan embraced the one
word philosophy they named their
business after their one word honest
Jessica and Christopher was disgusted by
how unhealthy many children's products
are they are laced with toxic chemicals
that haven't been properly tested they
were making kids and Jessica sick she
and Christopher got fed up so they
decided to be the change they wanted to
see in the world they launched the
artist company to provide non-toxic
eco-friendly fashionable and affordable
products for kids ranging from diapers
to bath and body products they believed
in their business so much that they
hired Jessica's mom to work for them
they loved their manifesto and products
so deeply that they hang them on their
wall jessica practices armas management
and the actress entrepreneur worked over
200 million dollars doesn't have her own
office she sits right alongside her team
they don't test their products on
animals they test them on their own
children they give 1% of the revenue to
charity in chemical research from the
employees to their suppliers they think
about the impact they're leaving on the
world to reduce their carbon footprint
everything they make is produced within
150 miles of Los Angeles and they shift
ground not air
they have unapologetically high
standards in products people and
business practices everything they do
has to match up with their artists
philosophy the results the honest
company went from zero to hundreds of
millions of dollars in sales after three
years in business the company was valued
at 1 billion dollars they are making
money and making an impact by following
their one word so I asked Christopher to
share his one word story early in my
career I was frustrated I was frustrated
with the lack of authentic relationships
in business I was frustrated when I saw
that everyone would promise you the
world and then there was no consistent
follow-up that's being totally dishonest
what I found was the levels of
transparency and authenticity and
clarity and willingness to tell the
consumer what was healthy and safe words
there and I'm thinking wow these are
products that we're using on our body in
our home on our children
we're ingesting them how is that
possible when my business partner
Jessica and I were developing our
concept we were imagining the world
dreaming big and what we wanted in it we
were thinking about what's the world we
wanted I love the beauty of the word
honest the simplicity to be honest is
something that everyone wants to do it's
an aspiration as well as a real-life
fulfillment it's an honor to hold that
word it's a privilege and it's a duty it
holds you to a standard and it drives us
forward every single day I wanted to
challenge ourselves to be honest what
does that mean that's a lot to live up
to I wanted to see if we could do it
we're constantly as a brand and as a
company pushing ourselves to really
achieve to be more and more honest every
single day everyone is here to see this
mission and purpose driven company
fulfill its core goal and a lot of it is
we're not here to build product we're
here to educate a new generation of
consumers and parents in our core
mission we don't talk about product we
talked about what's the change in the
world we want to see and
how do we accomplish that you have to
align yourself as what you believe is
right what I love about us we really act
on my heart and if it doesn't feel right
we're not going to go there honesty is
telling people the truth even though it
might be uncomfortable it's quality it's
saying what matters it's telling people
what you won't do and what's not inside
as opposed to what isn't done for
everything from a baby diaper to shampoo
the fruit and veggie washes to a range
of lifestyle products at the end of the
day a parent just wants to trust me i
guard that trust I state guarded every
single day it's the only thing we have
our credibility and Trust I am such a
strong passionate advocate of keeping
that trust and that level of
connectivity with the consumer and
letting them know we're doing everything
possible every single day to build and
improve on that level of trust and
connected relationship
you
you